a
en turquía aunque sea criticar levemente
al presente turco recep tayyp erdogán
acarrea consecuencias judiciales para
varios miles de personas cada año antes
de que erdogán fuese investido como
presidente turco en 2015 años antes
había sido ya primer ministro el número
total de personas condenadas por
insultos al presidente de un crimen muy
antiguo que data de 1923 fue de 44
personas en toda la historia de la
república de turquía desde 2015 hasta
2019 en el último año del que se tienen
datos han sido seis mil personas las
condenadas por este crimen insultos al
jefe de estado turco las redes sociales
han vuelto ahora mismo un sitio donde la
policía controla al dedillo cualquier
palabra o crítica que pueda recibir el
presidente turco y según muchos abogados
de defensa y de derechos humanos turcos
las denuncias de los fiscales turcos
contra gente que en sus dos presidentes
son diarias y casi por defecto
[Música]
en españa las injurias a la corona son
un delito que puede ser castigado con
hasta dos años de cárcel y son muchos
los casos de cantantes de políticos
activistas e incluso de periodistas de
revistas satíricas que fueron condenados
por este delito en la mayoría a multas
importantes pero está también el caso
del político hagan aldo otegi condenado
a un año de cárcel por decir que el rey
de españa era el jefe de los
torturadores para este caso como para
otros el tribunal europeo de derechos
humanos condenó a españa por vulnerar la
libertad de expresión y hay tanta
polémica aquí que incluso a finales del
año pasado se presentó una proposición
de ley para despenalizar este delito
pero fue rechazada por parte del
gobierno por el partido socialista entre
otros porque según ellos este delito
protege el honor y la reputación del
estado
i
ann chandler recibió la sentencia más
dura en la historia de tailandia bajo la
ley de lesa majestad esta ex funcionaria
fue condenada a 43 años y seis meses de
prisión por compartir audios en facebook
y youtube en los que se criticaba a la
monarquía el caso ha sido el símbolo del
endurecimiento de la ley aunque la norma
existe desde principios del siglo 20
tailandia la vida ha dejado de usar pero
esto cambió el año pasado cuando las
protestas sociales se recrudecieron por
primera vez los tailandeses comenzaron a
criticar abiertamente a la familia real
una de las más ricas del mundo en
noviembre del 2020
llegó la reactivación de la ley de lesa
majestad que dejara aprilia en la cárcel
por el resto de su vida
[Música]